- Hello, I'm Alice Kaplan, director of
the Whitney Humanities Center.
Welcome to the spring 2021
Finzi-Contini Lecture.
Before Meghan O'Rourke introduces
our distinguished speaker,
Hernan Diaz, I'd like to say
a few words about the history
and the tradition behind today's event.
The Finzi-Contini Lectureship
was endowed in 1990 by
the Honorable Guido Calabresi, judge of
the US Court of Appeals
for the Second Circuit
and former Dean of the Yale Law School.
It was also endowed by his brother
the late Dr. Paul Calabresi.
This lecture honors their mother,
Bianca Maria Finzi-Contini Calabresi.
She and her husband
Massimo, early activists in
the resistance to Italian
fascism fled Italy in 1939 after
the passage of the first
infamous racial laws.
They settled in New Haven to
start a new he as a physician,
she as a literary scholar.
Bianca Maria Finzi-Contini
earned her PhD in French
at Yale in 1949 with a dissertation on
the scholarly influences an
Ernest Renan secular upbringing.
Her subject Renan is one of
the most fascinating writers
of the 19th Century.
A free thinker and brilliant
analyst of nationalism
and of Christianity who
believed in racial hierarchies
but nonetheless counted among his enemies
the most vicious antisemites in France.
Lore has it that Professor
Ali Pyle, the director
of Bianca Finzi-Contini's thesis wanted
to appoint her to the faculty at Yale but
the 1949 Yale Corporation refused.
There would be no tenured
woman on the faculty at Yale
for another full decade.
Bianca Maria Finzi-Contini
went on to become professor
of French and Italian
at Connecticut College,
then chair of the department of Italian
at Albertus Magnus College.
Her last published volume was
also written in French like
her dissertation and it was
on Renan's relations with one
of the founders of classic philology.
She died in 1982 at the age of 80.
I'd like to take this opportunity
to thank Judge Calabresi
and his family for their
generosity and for giving us
the privilege of remembering
a distinguished alumni,
Bianca Maria Finzi-Contini.
The Finzi-Contini Lectures
sponsors a distinguished speaker
in the field of comparative
literature broadly defined.
Over the years the Whitney
has welcomed translators,
editors, theorists and
practitioners of literature.
The inaugural lecture in the
series was delivered in 1991 by
the great Italian semiotician Umberto Eco.
This year for the first time
the Whitney Humanities Center
is joining with The Yale
Review as co-sponsors of
the Finzi-Contini lecture.
It's my great pleasure now
to introduce the editor
of The Yale Review, Meghan
O'Rourke, who took over
the editorship of The
Yale Review in early 2020
as the magazine was celebrating
its 200th anniversary.
A graduate of Yale, Meghan
is an accomplished poet
and essayist, a former
editor at The New Yorker,
the Paris Review and Slate.
She's the author of
the bestselling memoir,
"The Long Goodbye" and
three poetry collections.
She's published essays on the
love poems of Thomas Hardy,
on Guantanamo, on John Ashbery
and on the early history
of young adult detective fiction.
She has spent this pandemic
year finishing her next book
of nonfiction on
appropriately enough illness.
She's the recipient of
many literary awards
including a Guggenheim,
a Lannan Fellowship
and two Pushcart Prizes.
So Meghan, I'm passing the
floor or the square to you
to introduce Hernan Diaz.
- Thank you, and sorry,
I clicked on too early
but all of nicer to share
the screen with you Alice.
Good afternoon everyone.
I am extremely pleased
to welcome Hernan Diaz
to give the Finzi-Contini lecture today at
the Whitney Humanities Center.
And I want to thank Alice
Kaplan and the center
for inviting The Yale
Review to be a co-sponsor
of this event.
We're very excited to say
that we'll be publishing
Renan's lecture in print
in our summer issue
which I'll remind you
of at the end so we hope
you'll subscribe or get a copy.
Okay, Hernan Diaz is the author of a study
of Jorge Luis Borges.
The Argentine essayist and poet titled,
"Borges, between History
and Eternity" as well
as the brilliant novel "In The Distance".
A finalist for the 2018 Pulitzer Prize and
the PEN/Faulkner Award among
many other citations that year.
In this novel, Diaz
turns the conventions of
the American Western on their
head, subverting expectations
and writing a work of fiction that in
the end becomes a profound
meditation on storytelling
on both the intimate and national scale.
Well, westerns are typically
set after the civil war,
this one is set before it.
And its hero is a recent
immigrant from Sweden,
Hakan Soderstrom, who doesn't
speak English from much
of the novel as he journeys
across America in search
of his lost older brother.
A journey that takes an
eastward toward New York city
rather than westward away from it.
In an interview, Diaz
referred to his novel
as a "Western Without Cowboys".
And noted that, "I
thought it was important
to quite literally
alienate the genre in order
to question the ossified
political assumptions
at its core."
The subverted western frame
in the distance asks us
to think about what and who
has been counted as American
in a history that has
whitewashed its own violence
and holds a productive
tension for the reader ideas
of foreignness and ideas of connection
as when Hakan, adrift
in a new world searching
for connection meets a scientist
who teaches him English
and introduces him to
the notion that the bond
between all living things
is the "true religion."
Most of all though, this becomes
a discerning astute frame
for thinking about why
we tell stories at all
and how they comfort us.
Over the course of the novel
Diaz reflects on this question
very profoundly, very
movingly, very voluminously.
And at one point we meet
Hakan reflecting on the fact
that his brother whom he's
missing that his story
is "endow the world with meaning" and
that through these
stories life was contained
becoming something that could
be examined and understood.
In today's talk, Diaz examines
the art of fiction in order
to help us better understand
how it offers us truths
we cannot find elsewhere
and how reading rather
than research might best help
the writer of fiction achieve
the goals of building a
persuasive new reality.
Diaz serves as an associate director of
the Hispanic Institute
at Columbia University.
Born in Argentina, he
was raised in Sweden.
Studied in London and New
York and now lives in Brooklyn
with his wife and daughter.
I very much recommend that
you read his novel it's one
of my favorite books of the last years.
Tonight he's going to
speak to us about fiction
for about 40 minutes and then
we'll take questions from
the audience and from me for about 10.
To ask a question and
I'll remind you of this at
the end we ask that you
please use the Q and A feature
at the bottom of the screen.
In the meantime please join me
in giving a very warm welcome
to Hernan Diaz.
Thank you so much.
- Hi Meghan.
Thank you for your extremely
generous introduction.
Thank you also Alice Kaplan, Diane Brown,
the Whitney Humanities Center and everyone
at The Yale Review for
this wonderful invitation.
And thank you all for being
here in one way or another.
It's an overwhelming
honor to be delivering
the Finzi-Contini lecture
and I'm truly humbling to see
so many of my heroes in the archives.
Alice just mentioned Umberto
Eco but Tzvetan Todorov,
Charles Rosen, W.S. Merwin are in there
and it's really an immense honor.
I would also like to thank
my friends Paul Stacey
and Eunice Rodriguez Ferguson
for the many conversations
I had with them as I wrote this text.
And I should also say that
Meghan's invitation arrived
as I was starting to work
with my editor on a novel
I have just finished.
This new book is very much
about the notion of fiction.
What does fiction mean?
How do stories shape our
perception of reality?
How can fiction alter and
even constitute reality?
I thought it would be productive
to present these questions
in an essay stick form after
having written the novel.
The essay has nothing to
do with the novel plot wise
of course because as you'll
hear in a moment this
is a concern I've had for many years now.
What does fiction say about the world and
the many ways in which we experience it
and moreover how does
fiction fit in the world?
So this talk will be as
Meghan said 40 minutes
and it's divided into five sections.
The title is of course a loving
pun on Henry James's essay
"The Art of Fiction" which
I'll reference in a moment.
The art of fiction.
Fiction writers are a famously
neurotic bunch haunted
by self doubt.
From time to time, this
unease spreads and swells
into a general state of
disquiet and even shock
as a fiction itself suddenly
realize to its dismay
that it's just fiction.
Why dwell on made up stories?
Why make them up in the first place?
One response has often
been to present fiction
as something useful, a
fabrication certainly
but one redeemed by serving a purpose.
Say religious instruction,
moral edification,
political enlightenment
or even self discovery.
The opposite response claiming
that stories serve no purpose
at all is just as common.
Fiction is an invention, yes,
but it's completely harmless,
irrelevant play, a pastime
detached from real life not
to be taken seriously.
The latest symptom of fiction's
tendency towards self doubt
is a more or less pervasive
referential fetish
as if a strict adherence
to verifiable facts
could dissipate this anxiety.
I'd be enabled to say
when this first started
but literature fixation
with accuracy seems
to be a relatively new phenomenon.
I wonder for instance when fiction started
to be fact-checked.
This impulse overlaps with the
thought that literature ought
to be researched an eloquent example of
the referential fetish.
Yet the notion of
research implies arriving
at verifiable results
through scientific protocols
and methods that don't
translate all that well into
the realm of fiction.
There is actually a much
better word for this process
and literature, reading.
Differentiating between these two terms
is not a mere quibble.
The free associations,
the haphazard hermeneutics
and perhaps above all
the emotional dimension
of reading have nothing
to do with research.
I would even claim that what
makes reading so compelling
and productive is precisely
it's lack of method
and yet the desire to get
it right which I think tends
to go well beyond the reasonable desire
of saving oneself from the
occasional embarrassment
of getting it wrong often prevails.
I see this happen to fellow
writers, I see it happen to me.
Another manifestation of
the referential fetish
is the increasingly strong
link between fiction
and confession or witnessing.
Consider autofiction and
other literatures of the self
that have gained so much
prominence over the last few years.
Here, that mysterious maxim
according to which one
should write about what one knows is taken
to solipsistic extremes.
The testimonial nature of these books
is not I believe unrelated
to the general sense
of anxiety around the
place of truth and fiction
and provides a hedge against the demands
of accuracy and research.
What is experienced, witnessed
or remembered need not
be corroborated by other means.
But differently, a perceived
lack of objectivity
is offset by a surplus of subjectivity.
The literature of the self
offers the promise of immediacy
and presents the first
person where it surrogate
as the guarantor of truth.
I was there, I did it, I remember it.
Eating a madeleine
however has never turned
anyone into Proust.
Even if there are many texts
in this autofictional vein
that I admire, I must ultimately
side with Mary McCarthy
who despite often smudging
the boundaries between fiction
and autobiography in
her own work declared in
the company she keeps with a brilliant pun
that "the home address of the self is not
to be found in the book".
Yet it seems that autofiction's
promise of closeness
and veracity has something to
do with the current prominence
of these kinds of texts.
The referential fetish then
seems to be an overcompensation
for the uneasy relationship
between fiction and truth.
This current obsession is not unrelated
to the alarming turn a public
discourse started taking
some four years ago.
We all know what happened,
incontestable facts,
scientific reports, election results
and even daily events
verifiable through our senses
were exiled from the realm of truth.
Meanwhile, the most outlandish
narratives were presented
as irrefutable reality.
I don't intend to discuss
here the damage this has done
to a number of institutions
and how it has eroded public
trust in them.
This has been the object of
abundant coverage elsewhere.
My concern rather is what
it has done to fiction.
Increasingly over the
past few years I've heard
and read a growing
number of people say they
have lost interest in fiction.
Reality had become so
daunting and the proliferation
of lies so overwhelming that
these people had neither
the time nor the desire to
turn to novels and stories.
The assumption here is that in addition
to being trivial make
believe and a waste of time,
a classic perennial objection
fiction is a betrayal
of truth, that it's just a fake.
But the opposite of truth
is not fiction but falsehood
and not all fictions are false.
Section two, a pack of lies.
Truth is not a tenant
we immediately expect
to reside in fiction.
Indeed, we have grown
used to understanding
the two categories in
opposition to each other.
Fiction may seem to be
true, it may emulate truth
and many believe this to be
fiction's greatest imperative
but it is often defined as an
imaginary construct that in
the end has little to do
with the pursuit of truth.
What is expected of made up worlds is
that they adequately mimic
the real one and short
of that, that these inventions
be internally consistent.
Disciplines with an avert claim to truth,
which include fields as
disparate as the hard sciences,
the law, journalism, have
always taken good care
to distance themselves from
fiction, a word they only deploy
as an insult.
Yet, I don't believe the
relationship between truth
and fiction to be one of
rivalry or mutual exclusion.
I am convinced that
truth resides in some way
at the heart of fiction.
In her author's note to
"The Left Hand of Darkness",
a science fiction novel
set on the remote planet
of Gethen, Ursula Le
Guin writes and I quote.
"Fiction writers at least in
their braver moments do desire
the truth to know it, speak it, serve it.
But they go about it in a
peculiar and devious way
which consists in inventing
persons, places and events
which never did and
never will exist or occur
and telling about these
fictions in detail and at length
and with a great deal of emotion.
And then when they are
done writing down this pack
of lies they say, there,
that's the truth."
But what sort of truth is this?
Excuse me, that was the end of quote.
I don't think it depends
on how accurately a certain
historical period is rendered in a novel,
how precisely a city is
mapped out in its pages
or how lifelike its characters maybe.
After all, "The Left Hand
of Darkness" takes place in
the future in a world
light years away from ours.
Nor do I think truth
in this context refers
to how successful the story
is at convincing readers
to suspend their disbelief no
matter how outlandish the plot
or the setting happens to be.
We call such success very similitude
which means quite literally
resemblance to truth.
But Le Guin draws a distinction
between the devious way
in which fiction proceeds by
making things up in detail
and the final result, this believable,
lifelike very similar pack
of lies aspires somewhat
paradoxically the truth
itself not just its likeness.
In short, truth here has little
to do with a correspondence
to referential reality, how
closely a story resembles life,
how much it adheres to empirical facts
or how accurately it may
capture a historical period
is not the point.
Nor are we considering the
epistemological dimension
of fiction or whether it should
be treated as a collection
of falsifiable statements.
The psychological side of
this issue, how faithfully
the words on the page may
mirror the author's intention
is equally irrelevant here.
Lastly, the plausibility of
the story is also an important.
Just because a realist novel
takes place in Britain during
the industrial revolution does not mean it
has a higher truth value than
a science fiction story set
on an imaginary planet
in the distant future.
What I think Le Guin is referring to then
and what I would like to
discuss here fully aware
of how vague this may
sound is how fiction rather
than presenting us with
truthful content shows us how
we experience truth.
Section three, experience.
Perhaps fiction aspires to
truth not by capturing the world
but by presenting the many
ways in which we capture
the world through experience.
The question that follows is of course
what does experience mean?
And I have two definitions
by two fiction writers.
In the art of fiction,
1884, Henry James writes,
"Experience is never limited
and it is never complete.
It is an immense sensibility,
a kind of huge spider web
of the finest silicon threads
suspended in the chamber
of consciousness and catching
every airborne particle
in its tissue."
That's James.
And in "Modern Fiction" of
1919, Virginia Woolf said
something actually quite
similar and I quote,
"The mind receives a myriad
impressions - trivial,
fantastic, evanescent, or engraved with
the sharpness of steel.
From all sides they
come an incessant shower
of innumerable atoms and as they fall,
as they shape themselves into
the life of Monday or Tuesday
the accent falls differently from of old."
A huge spider web of the finest
silicon threads suspended in
the chamber of
consciousness, writes James.
The image is as striking as its
implications are remarkable.
There seems to be a passive
quality to experience here.
Suspended the net sways
in our consciousness
almost forgotten and the cobweb
itself immediately conjures
up images of neglect and abandonment.
Airborne particles which
I suppose stand here
for external stimuli simply land on it.
There is no active reaching out.
Something similar happens
in Woolf's passage.
I quote again, "the mind
receives a myriad impressions"
she writes, "from all sides
they come an" incessant shower
of innumerable atoms."
Just like James with his
web, Woolf says we are hit
with different intensities by
events and impressions some
of which engrave themselves on the mind.
There is no active collection
nor is there a selection
or sifting through these
particles or atoms.
They simply fall and
shape themselves without
our intervention into what
we perceive to be our lives.
Not to the microscopic
scale of the metaphor
which gives it a
scientific objective slant.
Experience they both seem to be saying
is highly granular detailed
down to the atomic level.
And this is why it is never limited and it
is never complete.
Now given this, how should
fiction approach experience?
Again, James and Woolf
provide similar answers.
Let's go first with James and I quote.
"Catching the very note and
trick the strange irregular
rhythm of life, that is the
attempt whose strenuous force
keeps fiction upon her feet.
In proportion as in what
she offers us we see life
without rearrangement, do
we feel that we are touching
the truth, in proportion as we
see it with rearrangement do
we feel that we are being
put off with a substitute,
a compromise and convention."
That was Henry James, now Virginia Woolf.
She writes, "Life is not a series
of gig lamps symmetrically arranged.
Life is a luminous halo, a
semi-transparent envelopes
surrounding us from the
beginning of consciousness
to the end.
Is it not the task of the
novelist to convey this varying,
this unknown and uncircumscribed
spirit, whatever aberration
or complexity it may display
with as little mixture
of the alien and external as possible."
So life is limitless,
complex and uncircumscribed.
It is inapprehensible in its
every infinitesimal detail.
Life is not symmetrically arranged
but has a strange irregular rhythm.
It doesn't conform to
pre-established norms
but reinvents itself constantly
according to how the dust,
the particles, the atoms settles.
The task of fiction then
is to mimic experience
and present whatever has
been caught in its web
without rearrangement,
James even he uses italics.
Without rearrangement and
with as little mixture
of the alien and external
as possible, Woolf.
Just as experience does
not select it's stimuli
but merely receives them so
the writer should not tamper
with experience, reorganizing
it or tidying it up.
Sure.
I think any random page by
Woolf or James will disprove
their own precepts.
Who could seriously believe
that these two wonderful
control freaks of all
writers did not rearrange
or mix the alien and
external into what they wrote
with a certain idea of order in mind.
I would even claim that the
more they strive to capture
the strange irregular rhythm
of life the more they focus on
the semi-transparent
envelope surrounding us,
the more controlled,
arranged and formerly aware
the pros become becomes.
Honoring the opacity of life demands
great clear sightedness.
Rendering it's chaotic
complexity requires an equally
complex sense of order.
If their pros were insufficient evidence
the most cursory glance at
Woolf's diary or James' prefaces
would confirm this.
We are not perceiving machines,
our eyes are not cameras,
our ears are not recording devices.
There is nothing automatic
or passive about perception.
And unless we become like
Emerson, a transparent eyeball
that can see all because
it's part we're particle
of God we need to accept that
perception is rearrangement
and that multiple processes of selection
and readjustment are at play
as we experience the world.
Far from dismissing or concealing
them literature captures
and even reveals these processes.
It is precisely because it
rearranges and intervenes
from outside that fiction
imitates the way we perceive life
which is always through some sort
of substitute, compromise and convention.
And these three terms which James dreaded
so much define not only
literary forms and genres
but also language itself.
Substitute, compromise, convention.
Section four, the title is the field,
the window, the watcher.
In 1908, almost 25 years
after the publication
of "The Art of Fiction"
James wrote the preface
to the New York edition
of the portrait of a lady.
Here, the chamber of
consciousness has expanded
to become the famous house
of fiction from which
the writer gets a necessarily
partial view of life.
Gone from this house
are the cobwebs hanging
in his earlier essay.
No longer a passive figure,
the writer now needs
to peers holes in the wall
in order to get a view
of the world beyond.
There are, "A million possible
windows that could open up
to an incalculability
of range," says James.
The particular aperture the
writer creates will determine
which portion of that unlimited experience
can be perceived and narrated.
And I quote again from James.
"The spreading field, the human scene,
is the choice of subject.
The pierced aperture, either
broad or balconied or slit-like
and low-browed is the literary
form but they are singly
or together as nothing
without the posted presence
of the watcher without in
other words, the consciousness
of the artist.
That was Henry James.
The resident after all a
need to rearrange and frame
the strange irregular rhythm of life.
Form is what comes
between the thing watched
and the watcher.
Conditioning what we can
see and how we see it.
Expanding James is similarly, let's say
there are three types of stories.
Those that focus on the
spreading field outside the house
of fiction, those that are
concerned with the design
of the window framing that
view and those that focus on
the watcher or the
consciousness of the artist.
Of course this is schematic.
The categories overlap and good
fiction usually has element
of all three but perhaps you'll
bear with me and indulge me.
An emblematic novel in the
first group is "The Life
and Strange Surprising
Adventures of Robinson Crusoe,
of York, Mariner" written by himself.
Of course, the last part of
the title "Written by Himself"
already tells us where this is going and
the preface pen by an editor confirms it.
And I quote from this preface
it says, "the editor believes
the thing to be just
history of fact, neither
is there any appearance of fiction in it."
So whether it succeeds or not
the novel stakes its claim
on its truthfulness and
denies its fictional quality.
This is not fiction.
Narratives like this
compel us through a variety
of rhetorical means to
forget they are fictive.
They present us with a
world and ask us to pretend
that we take it for the real thing.
This group includes I think
most modern western fiction.
It was consolidated during
the rise of realism in
the 19th Century and
still holds sway today.
All those life-like stories
that regardless of genre
or how fanciful their setting
may be rely on readers
suspension of disbelief on
their accepting for a moment
that they're being
presented with the actual.
Even speculative novels like
Le Guin's may fall under
this category by the way.
So this is fiction that
wishes we could forget
that we're looking through
a framed pane of glass
and believe rather that we
are on the spreading field.
The second group, literature
that shows an avert concern
for the window has a strange history.
Consider the authors apology for this book
that precedes "The Pilgrim's
Progress" where John Bunyan
openly announces that the following pages
are a fable mere fancies which
rather than imitating life
are in the similitude of a
dream or a factory's preface
to vanity fair titled
before the curtain in which
the author introduces
himself as the manager
of the performance.
On the stage, they're not
even actors but puppets,
dolls and figures.
These are three words from the preface.
The manager's last gesture
in the preface is to bow
to his patrons and rise the
curtain to reveal the stage.
This curtain it's the
same one that James draws
to look out his window.
The window that stands let's
remember for literal form.
This brings me to the strange evolution
of fiction in this category.
I believe the apologetic
drive which can be one
with impulse to reduce
fiction to a mere allegory
or a fable that never asks to
be taken at face value became
the self-referential
gesture that defines so much
of what we may hastily
call experimental fiction.
I place in this group all
stories that draw attention
to the fact that they
are verbal fabrications.
Narratives that rather than
trying to pass for the truth
and now in different ways
their fictional status
and reflect on their formal configuration.
This includes all event called
literature that works on
the premise of alienation,
estrangement or distancing,
showing and drawing attention
to the artifice of it all.
Closer to our present time
what is known as metafiction
and other self-conscious
narratives may fall under
this category as well.
In short, all those novel
that Elizabeth Hardwick put
it in reflection on fiction show a degree
of panic about the form.
And finally, we have
the fiction focused on
the posted presence of the
watcher or in other words
the consciousness of the artist.
With a slight of hand in other words
is what James slips in there.
James conflates two very different worlds.
On the one hand, the watcher
is posted in the house
of fiction looking out
the window which makes
the watcher a textual being just like
the characters on the lawn.
On the other, the consciousness
of the artist refers
to someone from an
altogether different plane,
someone this side of the
book like the readers.
It is safe I think to equate
the watcher with a narrator
while the consciousness
of the artist is closer
to the author without of
course fully overlapping
with this extra literary presence.
Nothing in fiction neither
the scene nor the frame exists
without this perceiving
watcher, says James.
But this hybrid undecisive
ever mutating being
it's alternatively and
often simultaneously inside
and outside the text.
It's view is limited
by point of view which
is very much an internal
construction of the story
but it's also informed by the
consciousness of the writer
which isn't quite a literary occurrence.
This presence inhabits a liminal zone.
It can jump out the window
and join the party out on
the lawn as do all the
first person narrators
but it can also turn its back
to the window and face us.
I have always been drawn
to stories that revolve
around this presence
because they often try
to complicate inherited notions
of what literature may be
and they do so through the process
of unfolding themselves as literature.
The classic example would
be the nesting dolls
in "Donkey Xote" in which the distinctions
among author, narrator, character
and reader are in crisis.
Which means the distinction
between the inside
and the outside of the house
of fiction is also unclear.
Here are some of my favorite texts
that question these boundaries.
Machado de Assis does it
in "The Posthumous Memoirs
of Bras Cubas" in which
his dead character is also
the narrator who promises
to reach out of the book
and flick his reader in the
head if he doesn't like it.
Robert Walser does it in "The robber"
with his authorial interventions.
Macedonio Fernandez does it in "The Museum
of Eterna's Novel" a novel
made up of four words
to that novel.
Jorge Luis Borges does
it in several stories
by directly addressing and
involving the reader in
the plot by silently quoting himself
and by making several
hitchcock-like cameos.
Clarice Lispector does it in
"The Hour of the Star" in which
the narrator is a character
writing the story we're reading.
Muriel Spark does it in "The
Comforters", her first novel
in which the protagonist
literally hears the author type
her thoughts as she is thinking them
and we are reading them.
Samuel Beckett does it
through the pronominal shifts
in "Company", David Markson
does it masterfully over
and over again in his last four novels
where he appears pitched
against the entire Western-canon
under the name of reader,
protagonist, novelist or author.
This texts fold upon
themselves and in a mobius-like
contortion become their
own referential reality.
Gertrude Stein could not
have put it more clearly.
And I quote, "the more a novel
is a novel, the more a play
is a play, the more a
writing is a writing,
the more no outside is
outside, outside is inside,
inside is inside."
I distrust taxonomies and
grids of any sort applied
to literature but with this hesitating
and I'm sure a questionable
classification I hope
to show how fiction can have different
dispositions toward truth.
Fiction concerned with the
spreading field is true
because it mimics certain
unquestioning ways in which
we experience reality.
Fiction concerned with the
peers to aperture is true
because it's honest about
its own artificial status
and it makes us consider the
extent to which reality may
also be a framed narrative.
And fiction concerned
with the watcher is true
because it understands the
ambiguity and instability of all
the terms involved here mainly
reality, fiction and frame.
In the end, these are
all ways of experiencing
our relationship to the world which
at times can be immediate
and wholly immersive
at times painfully and
self-consciously distant.
Five and last, the emotion itself.
In October 1926, The Yale
Review published an essay
by Virginia Woolf titled "How
Should One Read a Book?" Which
is a wonderful essay
that we should all read.
A few pages into her piece she explains
the fiction writers work and
I'll quote here a little bit
at length but it's a beautiful text.
Woolf rights, "Perhaps the
quickest way to understand
the elements of what a novelist
is doing it's not to read
but to write, to make your own
experiment with the dangers
and difficulties of words.
Recall then some event
that has left a distinct
impression on you.
How at the corner of the street perhaps
you pass two people talking, a tree shook,
an electric light danced.
The tone of the talk was
comic but also tragic.
A whole vision, an entire
conception seem contained
in that moment.
But when you attempt to
reconstruct it in words
you'll find that it breaks
into a thousand conflicting
impressions, some must be
subdued, others emphasized.
In the process you will
lose probably all grasp upon
the emotion itself.
Then turn from your
blurred and littered pages
to the opening pages
of some great novelist,
Defoe, Jane Austen, Hardy.
Now, you will be better able
to appreciate their mastery."
That's the end of Woolf.
If James' view of the novelists
task changed over time
so did Woolf's during the seven years
that separate modern fiction,
the first text I quoted
from this text.
Here like there, impressions
are the point of departure.
Here like there, we are
confronted with the multifaceted
and uncontainable nature of experience.
And by the way, note the unstable light
illuminating both passages.
A semi-transparent halo in the first now,
a flickering bulb here.
As if to show us there is something opaque
and wavering about perception.
But instead of the
almost mystical passivity
that Woolf encouraged in modern fiction,
in this essay she acknowledges the need
to subdue some impressions
while emphasizing others.
Blurriness unless deliberately crafted
is not a desired outcome.
Without some sort of order
the myriad impressions
that fall on the mind are
mere litter on the page.
Crucially though, form
should be at the service
of keeping one's grasp
upon the emotion itself
and this brings me to my final thoughts.
To recapitulate fiction that
pack of lies is in pursuit
of its own form of truth.
I know this truth has
little to do with accurately
describing referential reality.
I suspect it may be related
to the attempt at presenting
the many ways in which
we experience the world.
I believe this attempt
to be mediated by form,
the individual choices and
inherited configurations
by which we rearrange our perceptions.
I also think that literature
is disposition toward form
the ways in which it
conceals, reveals and reflects
on its artificial nature
defines its distinctive
relationship to truth.
But this definition seems insufficient.
It reduces fiction to more
or less self-aware reports
on non-existent worlds.
These reports may mimic with
different degrees of success
the ways in which we
relate to the actual world,
still fiction does more than this.
It not only mimics experience,
it is itself an experience.
Let's return to Woolf.
She notes that a
hypothetical writer trying
to capture experience will
likely lose all grasp upon
the emotion itself.
Grasping an emotion, this seems to be
fiction's main purpose.
The emotion is what
needs to be conjured up
and preserved in the text.
It is this to which all
other elements including form
are subordinated because
form as George Eliot noted
in an 1868 essay is, "Not
only determined by emotion
but intended to express it."
I ought to underscore
at once that I am not,
most emphatically not speaking here about
the many vicarious
sentiments a story may seek
to exciten us as we read.
It's not about feeling
Captain Ahab's wrath,
Emma Bovary's desire or
Hans Cousto's malaise
as if these emotions were our own.
I'm referring rather to the
general feeling that fiction
when successful stirs in us
regardless of specific content.
In his lecture in Dickens,
Nabokov says and I quote,
"Although we read with our minds, the seat
of artistic delight is
between the shoulder blades.
That little shiver
behind is quite certainly
the highest form of emotion that humanity
has attained when evolving
pure art and pure science."
I must confess I've never
felt that shiver down my spine
to me it's more like a body-wide fist but
the point still stands and I agree.
Artistic delight is one
of the highest forms
of emotion we can experience.
And this I think is the
emotion Woolf is referring to
and without it fiction,
however formerly sophisticated
becomes simply a pack of lies.
In that same essay George
Eliot asks and I quote,
"What is fiction other than an arrangement
of events or faint
correspondences according
to a predominant feeling."
There is so much to love about this pithy
definition of fiction.
The main one for me is
the marriage between form
and feeling which again, I take
to be an aesthetic emotion.
One that is free from any
sort of correspondence with
the referential world.
For it has nothing to do with
imitating any passions in
our emotional palette.
A rush of courage or a pang
of guilt we may recognize in
this or that character.
The feeling of artistic
delight is conjured up by
the text itself and it's not
anchored to anything external.
Furthermore, it cannot be
found outside the text.
It is a literary event
exclusively because this
particular experience
has one defining quality.
Since literature's prime
material is language it follows
that this aesthetic emotion
will be not only a sensory event
as the delight we can find
in pure color or impure sound
but also a semantic one.
Fiction is not a collection of falsehood
or irrelevant fabrications.
It is rather a certain kind
of narrative that shows us
the many ways in which we
experience life whether it wishes
to accurately address
referential reality or not.
And it does so while adding
an experience to that life.
What happens to us this
feeling of plenitude when
we read fiction takes place
at the intersection of meaning
and emotion and it is
always mediated by form.
The physical enjoyment
of language in its visual
and oral dimensions.
The wonder of seeing
something come into being
as it takes shape in a sentence,
the many avocations a word
or paragraph may conjure up,
the miracle of time expanding
and contracting on the page,
the love a certain verbal
creature may inspire.
These are some of the ways
in which we experience
this intensity which shifts
fiction away from the imperative
of correspondence with
the empirical world.
And it is this emotion
that brings friction closer
to truth while freeing it
from its referential anxiety
showing us how much beauty
there can be in meaning.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much Hernan,
that was really wonderful.
So many ideas to think
about and unpack here
and sadly I know we won't get
to talk about all of them.
I want to remind our audience
that they can ask questions in
the Q and A even if we
don't get to talk about all
our questions today I hope
that you'll be able to read
the piece in the review and
that will be another way
to engage with this but I
thought I would start us off
and then turn to our audience.
I'm not sure where I wanna
start because there's
so many things I wanted to
ask about but I think I'd like
to start by returning to
what you just talked about
about this feeling of
plenitude when we read fiction
deriving from as you put
the intersection of meaning
and emotion and always mediated by form.
And I wonder if we could
pivot to talk a little bit
about writing fiction and how that sense
of plenitude comes into writing and how
you free yourself from
the referential adherence
that you talked about.
And that might take us
back to the very beginning
of the talk where you
talked about the difference
between reading and research.
And perhaps you could unpack
this a little bit more from
the writer's point of view.
- Well, thank you and I'm sorry I see
that I took a little
longer than anticipated
so I apologize for that.
How to escape the referential
anxiety during the process
of writing I think the
answer is contained someplace
within this talk.
I would like to say nothing
is as tidy and you're a writer
so you know this.
Nothing is as tidy as it comes
off in this presentation.
Everything is much more
it's a mess, it's whimsical,
it's not a controlled
environment at least for me,
maybe some people are more methodic.
But I would say that for
me it's always putting
at the center the
emotional aspect of writing
and I think that's the
beautiful thing about fiction
that it's a highly
intellectual endeavor but
at the same time it has to
be emotionally stirring.
That's true for all literature
and not just fiction,
it applies obviously to
poetry as well for instance.
So that's sort of my
inner calibrating device.
If I'm leaning toward one
side or the other I feel that
if you become too focused
on the intellectual side on
the formal side, you run
the risk of just building a
very beautiful but cold cathedral that
is completely uninhabited.
But on the other hand, if you
overplay the emotional side,
I mean, nobody's interested
in like feelings, right?
That's unmediated feelings
are a little yucky so yeah.
- Or at least as I tell
my students you could have
the biggest feelings
in the world and sadly
they do not translate to the
biggest productions, right?
- Yes.
- (Indistinct).
You talked in some interviews
I read about this distinction
between reading and research
and I thought it was so astute.
I remember having a moment writing a poem
where I had done a lot of
research into 19th Century books
where I had kind of put in some
detail about pigskin vellum
and I thought no, no, this
speaker of this pump would not
be thinking about her book this
way, it would just be right.
So part of what you seem to
get at in this distinction
between reading and research
that I think applies back
to what you're talking
about here, is the idea
that it's not verisimilitude
necessarily that you're looking
for it's this more complex
dimensional world-building.
I guess sort of combination
of world and effect building
but I was wondering what
that actually looks like in
the distance is set in a
time that is not our time.
So how do you distinguish
you are in a sense
doing research, right?
But clearly there's a distinction for you.
How do you put that into
practice and what does it mean?
- Well, there is a distinction for me
and I hope I'm not doing
research as defined a moment ago.
I have to say also I was
trained as an academic
so I do have like a lot of
experience with archival work
and library work.
I'm actually at the New
York Public Library now
where I'm not doing research.
And so on the one hand
that gives me some sense
of discipline which I
think is really important
like sticking with it even if
it's like inhabiting boredom.
I think it's a very important
part of being a writer.
I think it's crucial.
But it's not research
in the traditional sense
because I am not out to
corroborate some contextual facts
or trying to make my post more accurate.
To give you like very quick
examples, the kind of stuff
that I'm looking for it's very weird.
I'm looking for instance for
little, how can I put it?
Little verbal prompts
for example, in the case
of the 19th century that I
think we'll do a lot more work
than really figuring out what
happened truly blow by blow
at the whatever Mountain
Meadows Massacre which
is important to know.
But I think if you find that little word
that will almost alchemically
conjure up a whole universe
that is worth more than all
the fact checking in the world.
And I get to those words
by just reading a lot
while I'm writing.
I know a lot of writer friends
don't even read fiction
as they write their own
fiction, I'm the opposite.
Like I read all of Dickens
while writing "In The Distance"
and that somehow gave a sense
of 19th Century language
that you can only get that
way just by being immersed in
that world and I don't think
that's necessarily research.
- No, I love this distinction.
It's very useful to me personally.
I'm gonna ask one question
from the audience and then
that's probably all we have time for.
- Sorry.
- No, we wanted to hear
your wonderful talk.
We had a member of the audience
ask what advice do you have
for authors who are setting
stories even partially outside
their own cultural experience,
in nations they don't know
or among people whose identities
the author doesn't know, yeah.
- Yeah, that's a really
complicated question.
I think and it's something
that I deal with myself.
I don't find that I write
necessarily about myself
and my environment.
I think the first question
is why do you need
to tell this story?
I think that's the question
that you need to ask yourself
and be dead honest with yourself about it.
Why do you need to go
into this world when it
is not given to you?
And I think that the
second element is never
to be a tourist in that
world and to really try
to understand it.
And if you understand
why you need to go there,
chances are that maybe you
will also understand why
you were drawn to it in the first place
but I think it's a longer answer of course
and I understand it has a
lot of political connotations
but I think we should all be brave enough
to venture outside our
world and write about others
because otherwise
literature will be reduced
to a selfie in a way.
- I love that distinction of the tourists.
I do wanna get to one more question
if you're patient enough
Hernan to do one more.
- Of course.
- Judge Calabresi who is here did
ask a question and I'd love
to hear the answer to and he
said, as you were talking,
I kept thinking about my
reaction that seeing a work
of visual art and how similar that was.
Do you feel is there a difference?
- Excuse me, can you repeat that?
Oh, it's here, okay.
Oh yes, no, absolutely.
And thank you Judge Calabresi
for being here by the way.
It's a great honor I didn't
know you were in the audience
and for making this series possible.
Definitely, I think it's very important
to have almost like a cenesthetic
approach to literature.
I think visual vividness is all important
but I'm also very interested
in the auditive dimension
of pros and how evocative sounds may be.
I think literature gives
us this opportunity
and you Meghan as a
poet know all about this
but just the way a word looks and sounds
and how it interacts with its meaning
is such a beautiful thing
to use to one's advantage.
- Well, this has been really wonderful.
Thank you so much Hernan.
Thank you all for coming today.
I know we're sad not to be
in a physical space together
but we're really glad to be in
this virtual space together.
I'm delighted again to tell
you the talk will be published
in the summer issue of The Yale Review.
You can subscribe at our
website or pre-order the issue
if you're interested.
And thank you again to Alice Kaplan and
the Whitney Humanities
Center for hosting this event
and having us all here.
Thank you everyone have
a wonderful evening.
- Thank you Meghan, thank you everyone.